first question for both of you can you
each tell me something about the other
as a scene partner that you appreciated
maybe even something they did to help
you reach something in your own
character that you might not have been
able to without them well I will say
this I am a person who I mean I I work
hard at my
job um but I there's always this
internal feeling inside of me as soon as
you hear
action I'm I'm ready for it to be done
I'm ready to hear cut and I think the
time that I was able to share that
creative space with Mersa and
his his thoughtfulness and and his sort
of elegant way of holding that space and
time um it sort of made me more aware of
my inside clock and I think I I think I
was able to slow those moments down for
myself in a way that was new for me a
beautiful answer can you top that Mersa
I don't think I can top it but I can say
that what I loved and really appreciated
about working with Julia was this inner
sense of always saying yes so if Sam
wanted to do wanted us to do something
different or if something felt
challenging there was this willingness
to to say yes and try it and
um acting projects they can become these
things where people start eating each
other up through being pessimistic and
it can go downhill or you could be
around people that have cuz film making
is very difficult and things always go
wrong so you can have people that are
constantly looking for the light and you
can kind of follow there and create
something beautiful together and so that
was my experience in working with you so
thank you so much very much sounds like
the same is true of this entire ensemble
everyone is exceptional in this too the
specific scene I have to ask you both
about I need to know everything about
that delightful dance scene was that
song Always scripted how did you find
the specific dance moves that you
thought like suited your character in
that moment best too there was a lot of
rehearsal time for that a lot of it was
just talking about how to hold the space
how to share the space how to be apart
from each other how to be close to each
other a lot of it was just me being able
to look up into maha's eyes and not have
my cheeks turned red and start kind of
getting teary eyed and giggly like a
15-year-old girl um there was a lot of
that and you were very patient and sweet
and and it's a complicated scene I mean
we were just talking it's maybe for us
one of the harder
scenes that we had together in the movie
definitely I think they're going going
to kick me out I'll try to squeeze in
one more in case someone yells at me
just a silly question to end on here
about Disaster Movie scenarios so let's
say real world real you there is a
blackout just like what happens in this
film you can team up with one Leave the
World Behind co-star who do you choose
that you think will give you the best
chance of surviving it would be you
we're together we yeah we survived it
already yeah not Sam and not Ethan cuz
they just they both be like what do we
what right and they've said that yeah
fair enough fair enough I believe it all
right I have to let you go I'm going to
say huge congratulations on this movie
love the book love the movie love having
two versions that are exceptional
congratulations thank
you